[Music]
happy birthday roger goodell he turned
60 today but a more significant birthday
for our purposes number 22 of the
minnesota vikings not harrison smith
paul krauss hall of famer who turned 77
today and he is still even though he
last played 40 years ago he is the
all-time interception leader in nfl
history with 81.
he passed emilyn tunnell late in his
career with 79 the next closest guy is
rod woodson with 71.
the active leader right now in the nfl
is reggie nelson with 38. he's tied for
91st with 38 isn't it amazing that in
this day and age with all the passing
that's done
there are fewer interceptions than there
used to be yes i don't how can how do we
how do we reconcile that well there's
more ways to get cheap completions you
know of course the rules are favored for
the offense more and you know there's
offenses and quarterbacks are better now
than they were then and it was a
different type of game like i always go
back to something my dad used to say
like or bill parcells used to tell my
dad in the mid 80s he would always want
him to be aggressive push the ball down
the field he would tell my father if you
don't throw an interception you're not
being aggressive enough in this football
game so i think there was a different
mindset that way
but it is kind of fascinating that we do
throw the ball more now there's more
yards and less interceptions it just
speaks to what the game is but i didn't
realize this guy was that tall that was
the one thing that jumped out to me when
i watched highlights of him last night a
little bit you do you vividly remember
watching him in your younger years of
the vikings
yes thank you for uh sticking the knife
into my side over that i vividly recall
that paul krauss failed to help nate
wright over the top at the end of a
certain playoff game in 1975 when drew
pearson pushed off of nate wright and
paul krauss got there way too late to
keep drew pearson from catching the
game-winning touchdown pass from roger
staubach that coined the term hail mary
yeah oh here we go i do have vivid
recollection of that here we are in a
segment we're trying to say something
good about the guy and you got to bring
the whole segment down about the one
play he didn't do something in his
career then why the hell did you buy his
jersey then you got his jersey and you
said you were going to wear it today
where the hell is it
but i bought his jersey because
i am a glutton for punishment
and i always want to remember that pain
from late december of 1975 when he could
have had interception number 82 although
it wouldn't have counted because it was
in the postseason i digress yes i did i
i couldn't find his jersey i don't know
where it is i didn't burn it though like
people are doing with antonio brown's
jersey i still have it somewhere okay
good yeah so yeah there it is so you
lost that jersey already i mean are you
kidding me i i don't know where it is
it's in the house somewhere okay it's a
big house i i lose things all the time
all right uh
let's let's pivot now to why we brought
this up because his record is one that
that i i don't think is going to be
broken anytime soon definitely not in my
lifetime which hopefully will extend a
few more years but what are the records
in the nfl that come to mind for you
that just we can just assume will never
be broken give me one well i look at the
emit smith all-time rushing leader uh
and that's one that certainly pops out
to me and of course it's a popular one
but you know i just think with this day
and age the game is as physical as it is
i have a hard time believing that a
running back can last long enough to
eclipse that mark about edmond smith i
mean that's the great thing about emmitt
smith yeah i mean i would call emma
smith one of the two or three greatest
running backs of all time but he's
certainly up there in the rankings had a
great offensive line but i think one of
the best things about him was his
durability and his ability to be
consistent year after year after year
even when you know some of the physical
skills did go downhill so that's one for
sure i look at in the modern day nfl and
go man that is going to be tough to top
18 355 yards
yeah and because we are past that era of
every team having a workhorse running
back who gets the ball 25 to 30 times a
game teams like to have two or three
tailbacks to distribute the reps for a
variety of reasons one of which is
business because if you have one guy who
becomes that workhorse and is scoring
all those touchdowns and generating
those yards you got to pay him a ton of
money if you have two or three you can
manage your cap more effectively and you
can make the argument that there are
plenty of guys out there who can do what
one guy would otherwise do but you're
right about the durability of emmitt
smith that was his biggest skill and
we've talked about the 1993 game week 17
against your dad's giants with the you
know that he had the busted shoulder and
he kept going and the one seed was on
the line and they went on to win the
super bowl so it is amazing what what
emma smith didn't in that same vein i
know adrian peterson got close to the
eric dickerson single season rushing
record seven years ago i i don't see
that 2105 i it's just the game has
changed and as we see more and more
passing there are going to be fewer and
fewer big rushing performances fewer and
fewer workhorse tailbacks that 2105 is i
think emmett's is going to be harder to
beat but i still think 2105 is something
that's going to stand for a long time as
well well yeah that is that's i mean
that's a phenomenal feat with eric
dickerson there i mean just to get to
is hard enough and yeah i mean it is
hard to think that a team would be you
know running the ball consistently this
day and age to get their running back
2100 yards what about the brett favre
one 297 straight starts do you think
that goes by the wayside anytime soon
like there's a part of me that thinks
yes there'll only be a matter of time
because of the way the rules are
protecting the quarterback that we will
have somebody within the next you know
10 to 15 years break that even though
that's a truly remarkable feat in itself
as well you know that's a great point
the other side of that is we're so
sensitive now to injuries health
concussions yeah there were probably
more than a few games along that path
that brett favre would have been ruled
out for a concussion if the nfl had been
as sensitive for the bulk of his career
i mean he his last year was 2010 the nfl
had its concussion epiphany in 2009 so i
don't know that you can pull it off from
that perspective but
as the game protects quarterbacks more
and more
there's there's less of an opportunity
to have those concussions so right maybe
maybe someone can pull it off and it
would have to be a guy who was very good
about avoiding contact we obsess over
that all the time for good reason the
more hits you take the more likely you
are to get injured but farv took the
hits he just was able to keep going and
remember he had the painkiller addiction
he couldn't use painkillers and he still
found a way to keep playing week after
week after week after week yeah i know
that's what's amazing i mean he played
in some of the old school era football
too to where he stayed healthy through
that time period which is amazing too i
mean brett favre is special we know that
here's another one that i thought like
the single season touchdown record right
ladainian tomlinson he had 31 back in
2006. that's one i look at and go you
know back to the running back
conversation where there is a running
back by committee now in the nfl by the
most part and we don't wear the running
back into the ground like we used to in
the early 2000s and 90s you know 31
touchdowns in a single season the
closest we've had in modern football you
know just here recently gurley with 21
this year is really as close as it's
gotten because we've gotten away from
the priest home sean alexander john
riggins tyrell davis type of runner
where they give him the ball like you
said 25 times a game that's another one
i look at that i don't think it's going
to fall by the wayside anytime soon
and the bottom line is those guys end up
costing a ton of money remember when
sean alexander finally got his big
contract from the seahawks after he was
the mvp in 2005 they were done with him
after only one season that big contract
you you you have to have multiple
running backs if you want to avoid
creating this guy that everyone loves
that scores all the touchdowns it's on
everyone's fantasy team and then you've
got to pay him huge money and teams
realize that it's better to have
multiple and and who's going to get 31
touchdowns then it's not going to be a
receiver because the quarterback isn't
going to force the ball to one guy all
the time and there isn't a guy out there
i mean what's the record for touchdown
receptions for receiver stats 23.
yeah right randy moss in 2007. which was
a you want to talk about another amazing
feat he got that in 2007 to tie jerry
rice right who did it in 1987 in a
strike a short season season because of
the strike that's another one that i
look at and just go i mean as far as
touchdowns per game and i know we're
getting off a little bit of all-time
records but for him to have 23
touchdowns jerry rice in 1987 which was
a strike shortened season is truly one
of the greatest individual seas single
season feats in the history of football
i mean that to me
blows me away because i remember the
randy moss 2007 season and it felt like
he was catching multiple touchdown
passes every week i can't imagine jerry
rice in 87 with less games i mean he was
on fire that just speaks to his
greatness as well
22 touchdown receptions in only 12 games
that year for jerry rice because of the
strike i got one more yeah
and and this dovetails with paul krause
and his
81 career interceptions a guy named let
me make sure i get his name right i
don't want to defame anyone jim hardy
back in 1950 threw eight interceptions
in one game
eight interceptions he had three in the
first half and he said after the game i
felt really low at halftime i can
remember sitting on a bench in the
locker room with my head in my hands
thinking that nothing could be worse
than throwing three interceptions in one
half
that is great
that that never will be beat because
you're gonna get yanked you're gone
you're on the bench you're not gonna
have a chance to throw another eight
interceptions in today's nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports